The tally of death and destruction
keeps growing in the Northern
California wildfires.
Thick clouds of ash are
turning day into night.
2020 has been another
record setting wildfire season.
Over the last few years,
wildfires have been raging
not just in the Western US,
but all around the world.
Fires in the Amazon rainforest
and Australia's brush fires are so massive
that they can be seen from space.
And while fires have
long been a natural part
of many forest ecosystems,
higher temperatures
and longer droughts
caused by climate change
are drying out forests and
turning trees into tinder.
Meaning that in areas like California
wildfire seasons have become supercharged.
Towns like Paradise, California,
where the 2018 Camp Fire
destroyed over 80% of its homes
are now grappling with how to
adapt to this new age of fire,
starting from essentially the ground up.
It is literally like the
surface of the moon there.
Two years later, as the town still works
to rebuild, the local parks
and recreation district
is beginning an ambitious plan
to not just restore Paradise but make sure
it can better defend
itself from the next fire.
CityLab reporter Laura Bliss
went to see this firsthand.
So Laura, you just went to Paradise.
Can you sort of explain what's
it like to be there now?
It was a pretty haunting experience.
Just thousands and thousands
of homes literally reduced
to shells, kind of gutted out foundations.
It really still is this
landscape of disaster.
So I guess what has the scale
of rebuilding been like?
I checked with the city
and there's been about 400 homes
that have already been reconstructed
and about 1200 that are
currently permitted.
Even as this kind of instinct to rebuild
is sweeping over the town
and over former residents,
there are some people who are thinking
a little bit differently
about what the future
of Paradise should look like.
One resident I spoke to
has actually gone forward
with selling her land so that eventually
it might become part of a
large green belt encircling
the city to potentially protect
it from future wildfires.
And the person who's leading this project
is not a member of city government.
He's actually the manager
of the Paradise Recreation
and Parks District.
My name is Dan Efseaff,
I'm the district manager
for the Paradise Recreation
and Park District.
So we've provided everything
from swimming lessons
to people's first sports experience,
to hosting a variety of clubs.
And we've been a fabric of
the community for decades.
There were quite a few lessons
from the Camp Fire for us.
One of them was the role
we potentially have as a parks district.
And Dan believes what the park district
can start to do is improve.
What's known as the
wildland urban interface
It's that line between full-blown nature
and wildland areas, and then
the more developed space.
In Paradise that line
was very much blurred
or a razor's edge.
So the idea here is
that we would take that
very narrow razor sharp
wildland urban interface now,
and expand it out in such a way
that we would have a buffer.
At the same time, providing these kinds
of extraordinary recreational
resources and opportunities.
Dan and the parks and recreation district
are in the very early
phases of acquiring land
in hopes of connecting them in what would
be basically a giant moat of green space.
So if the nascent plan is fully realized,
thousands of acres of land could be used
for respite and play by
the residents of Paradise.
Parks and baseball
fields could also double
as future fuel breaks for fire.
So areas that could be parks
they could be returned in
some cases to orchards.
We're interested in
ag-tourism in the area.
So we're trying to do is take this idea
of defensible space around a house
and expand that to defensible
space around the community.
This plan is taking
shape now as California
and all of the Western US is on fire.
Already this year, millions
of acres have burned,
tens of thousands of people
have had to evacuate.
With climate change
driving up temperatures
and drying out forests there's
no question that the risk
of catastrophe recurring in
communities like Paradise
and Paradise itself, is very, very real.
But for Dan, he's hoping that this plan
can make Paradise not just a dire warning
of the damage wildfires can cause
but rather a model on how to
better protect communities
in fire prone regions.
Earthquake!
If major cities all up
and down the West Coast
that sit on major earthquake faults.
We've mitigated that,
we've engineered our way
into having less danger associated
with earthquakes in major cities.
And we can do the same with fire.
We just haven't done it yet.
This is Crystal Kolden.
She's a geographer by training.
I call myself a pyro geographer
because almost all of my work
over the last 15, 20 years
has been across this really broad spectrum
of understanding how
humans and the environment
are affected by and interact with fire.
There are a lot of different factors
that contribute to changing wildfires,
but climate change is the thing
that amplifies all of those changes.
So when we have a high temperature,
there's a lot more heat
and that heat translates into fires
being able to burn more easily
and because they're able
to burn more easily,
the conditions are dryer,
they're able to burn a lot
hotter and a lot faster.
And they're much, much more difficult
for firefighters to contain.
While around the country
the number of wild land
fires have actually been
going down since 1990.
The acres burned has at times doubled.
The idea in Paradise is to
use what's called a greenbelt
to help slow the
destructiveness of future fires.
Green belts are a type
of fuel break, right?
Greenbelts are of course,
these areas where a lot
of the understory is removed under trees
so that they become essentially
park-like grasslands.
This is one of the jewels of our area.
This is Paradise Lake.
This was a location where
the fire slowed down
and stopped on its own.
You can definitely see evidence
of fire through this area,
but the flame lengths are
relatively low on these trees.
Look at all of these
small trees that were cut.
These were cut before the fire.
So that created a more open understory
which carried the fire less
than it would have otherwise.
Dan wants to use the
land that they acquire
to create more areas that look like this.
We are going to pursue a strategy here.
These oaks that are sprouting
up, make them less bushy
make it less of a brush field over time
and encourage one particular
leader out of here
to grow into a tree.
It's really important to
note that it's not gonna be
as simple as just planting
some trees and grass
and hoping for the best.
Firebreaks are not invulnerable
to the spread of fires.
High winds, especially
the ones that we've seen
igniting some of the fires
of these catastrophic events
in the last couple of years
can carry burning embers as far as a mile.
A common misconception that people have
is that a fire break should
just stop a fire, right?
That's the definition, right?
It's meant to break a
fire's forward progress
and it should do it all by itself.
And that's really a misconception
because that is not what the
goal of a firebreak usually is.
It is specifically
meant to be a safe place
for firefighters to take a stand
and try and modify a
fire's forward progress
as it's coming into a community.
You know, I keep thinking
about this with a story that
pulling off this green
belt feels like a lot
for a parks and rec district to pull off.
How much does something like this cost?
I think Dan's back of
the envelope calculation
was that this is going to
require upwards of $10 million.
And then that's not even including,
what it's going to take to
maintain all of these lands.
So just to give you a sense
of what this would entail,
one of the sections that Dan is targeting
for this green buffer
idea is a stretch of land
that runs parallel to
the Feather River Canyon.
It's about seven miles long
and about 4,000 acres in total,
containing hundreds of properties,
about 80% of that area is privately owned.
So on top of the costs
of acquiring the land,
it's also just the time and resources that
a little parks districts may
be challenged to work up to.
Turning these former homes into parkland
also hits on the ultra-sensitive question
of planned relocation, which is this idea
of government basically
coming in to assist
whole communities of people
move to an area that's safer
from a climate change perspective.
And that's a really difficult question
in a community that's already
been deeply traumatized
by this catastrophic experience.
We're absolutely of the mind
we have to be respectful
of all our decisions by landowners.
I think the idea is right now
that there is such a receptivity
to people wanting to do some
things that help the community.
Even if they choose to rebuild,
then maybe they will provide an easement
or permission to have that trail that goes
through the bottom of their property
that allows for fuels reduction,
It protects their property
in exchange for a little
bit of recreational value.
I think that idea is pretty persuasive
for a lot of people in our community.
Another issue Dan faces is that while
there's a lot of anecdotal
evidence that greenbelts can help
there actually isn't that
much scientific evidence
that confirms their effectiveness.
One conservationist I
talked to for this story
referred to green buffers
as this funny combination of common sense
with not a lot of scientific backup,
but experts say that the
signs are definitely out there
that it can work.
It's something that is
not really making it
into the scientific literature
because it's been relatively rare.
We don't have this rigorous
reproducible scientific process
that is often favored
by scientific journals.
But the anecdotal data are
very much supportive of this.
I actually published a study last year
about a series of firebreaks
and what was essentially a green belt
around the community of
Montecito California.
Between the years of 1999 and 2017
Montecito would spend over $1.6 million
on wildfire vulnerability
reduction activities.
And over years they did
it little by little.
It's individual properties,
it's along roads
where they have space to work.
And when we actually went back
and looked at the satellite data
it looks a little bit
like a green necklace.
And in 2017, the Thomas fire
would put that work to the test.
The calmer conditions in
Santa Barbara County Wednesday
didn't mean flames stopped threatening
multimillion dollar homes in Montecito.
This is the fifth largest
fire in California history.
And when that fire hit Montecito
there were winds blowing
over 60 miles an hour.
There were gusts up to 72 miles an hour.
And that was the last
thing we had recorded
before the weather station burned down.
And when it got to that green belt
along the edge of the town,
it basically did exactly
what the Greenbelt was designed to do,
which is it died down,
it allowed firefighters
to move in close and
work safely to put water
on the edge of the fire
to actually drop it down
to the ground and put it out.
And it is one of the
few cases that is really
well-documented
retrospectively and spatially
of a greenbelt working well.
We're trying to find more of
those, but it's a challenge.
What we're talking about is an idea
how do we live with
fire on this landscape?
Potentially we could serve a model
on a whole bunch of different levels,
not just the parks and how
to protect the community
but how do we take care of our people?
We can do all the science we want
but if people don't see
how it applies to them
and how it can translate into an action
that they can actually
take, then the science
doesn't actually become applied
in any way, shape or form.
And we don't change actions on the ground.
There's been a lot of interest
in how do we protect Paradise.
There's lessons here.
We're far enough along
that we can demonstrate
some of those lessons to
those unfortunate communities
that have suffered very
similar situations.
But also there's models
in here that are gonna
help people live better lives
in these mountain communities.